чому ми не в НАТО нагадаємо спікеру
фантомні болі минулого коли про
московські політики подарували деяким
Україно скептикам тезу що не вся Україна
за Ната і тижнями Нестор тут в усім на
люстрі як фронтмен цієї акції на коні
чому Україна не в НАТО Можливо тому що
на другий день після інавгурації
президента Зеленського до дбр Нестор
літописец подав паски про те що
Президент Порошенко винен у Контрнаступ
і то ми оці от пасхилів розслідувалися
всі ці роки за те що Президент Порошенко
посмів дати наказ
звільняти українську Донецьк і Луганськ
і ви знаєте що цей пасхиль не закрито і
досі в листопаді 22-го року дбр які в
перші місяці війни втікли звідси
продовжили цей і досі розслідується
справа про Контрнаступ про звільнення
українського Донецька і Луганська Мені
цікаво ці люди відкриють потім
кримінальну справу про Контрнаступ
Зеленського чому ми не в НАТО Можливо
тому що в нас немає свободи слова
Можливо тому що в нас і досі марафон
Можливо тому що телеканал Рада не
показує опозицію чому ми не надто тому
що Нестор Шуфрич і досі голова комітету
свободи слова вам не соромно всі вам не
соромно ми вимагаємо поставити на
голосування Постанову яку ми
зареєстрували щоби людину яка тягла
Україну в Руській мир скільки років
зняти хоча б з голови комітету свободи
слова це має бути наша спільна
відповідальність Я бачу що людям слугах
народу є яким соромно так зробіть свої
фракції хоч щось революційне і
Допоможіть нам що без справедливості
залі сьогодні була дякую